في الورقه التي قدمتموها في المنتدى
تحدثتم عن طريقه
معالجه الازمات في المناطق اللي فيها
صراعات او المناطق الهشه
دعني اخذ سوريا على سبيل المثال سوريا لم
تخرج من ازماتها ازماتها متكرره بدءا من
الحرب والان الكوليرا
والزلزال ايضا اضاف الى هذه الازمات كيف
تستطيعون القيام بعملكم في ظل وجود كل هذه
الازمات في ظل جو يسيس كل شيء حتى
المساعدات كما لاحظنا مؤخرا
يقولون الكنانه في الامم المتحده سواء عبر
اميننا العام وزملاء العاملين في المنظمات
الانسانيه ولا سيما في برنامج الامم
المتحده الانمائي لدينا ايمان عميق باننا
موجودون هنا لنبقى في الشام فالامم
المتحده تعمل في بعض اصعب النزاعات واشدها
التعقيدا سواء في اليمن او ليبيا او هايتي
او لكن دعيني اكون صريحا في الموقف في
سوريا تكرر سواء عبر الجانب الانسانيه
والازمه عموما بان هناك مازقا سياسيا
وهناك استقطاب عميق جزء من ثمان ذلك ان
ازيد من 94% من السوريين يعيشون تحت خط
الفقر هذا ثمن باهض جدا اولا يدفعه
السوريون وثانيا اننا محدودون في التحرك
والاستجابه هناك مساعده انسانيه للسوريين
ولكن الى حد ما فبرنامج الامم المتحده
الانمائي يعمل سوريا لكن هناك عدد من
الحدود الصارمه التي سطرتها المجموعه
الدوليه والتي لا يمكننا التحرك خارجها
ليس مسموحا لنا المشاركه في اعاده التعمير
فنحن نساعد فقط في عمليه التعافيه المبكره
وفي بعض الاحيان علينا ان نتناقش بشان
الاولويات وان نختار بين ان ندعم عمليات
التعافيه المبكر او بالسماح للنساء
بالتنقل داخل وبين القرى والمدن او ان
نشارك في اعاده تعمير تلك المناطق هكذا
وفي بعض الاحيان كيف تعقد التوترات
السياسيه عملنا ولكن في النهايه نحن
مؤمنون بانه وحتى نستمر باداء اعمالنا في
سوريا فان التنميه ينبغي ان تكون جزءا من
ذلك ولذلك على كل الاطراف ان تتجاوز
خلافاتها السياسيه وان تتفق على الاولويات
التي من مصلحتها كلها الالتزام بها بما
يقودنا في النهايه الى تعزيز الامل في
المستقبل